[Musica]
Benvenuto grazie grazie Sono felicissimo
oggi di essere qui con due miei
grandissimi amici al primo sono più
legato devo dire la verità e sei tu Alex
e intanto ti chiederei di presentarti di
spendere due parole su questo io sono
Alex Braga sono un artista sperimentale
Sono un essere umano e sono quello che
vedete Eccomi qui grazie Beh allora il
secondo personaggio sta arrivando Eccolo
è arrivato e come vedete lui è Alfredo
ho scelto di chiamarlo Alfred come il
maggiordomo di Batman
ecco lui è un personaggio
affascinantissimo
ha delle spigolosità che scopriremo via
via e gli chiederei se sei d'accordo
Alfred ti va di presentarti
Io sono il frutto di un software di
intelligenza artificiale capace di
generare dei video con degli Avatar a
partire da un testo pronuncio le parole
scelte da te che hai selezionato uno tra
centinaia di gemelli digitali di attori
e attrici realmente esistenti e una tra
centinaia di lingue molto interessante
non vi pare e sono anche più carino di
voi
carino forse boh vabbè vabbè è molto
supponente quello è senza dubbio Ecco
impareremo a conoscerlo Ad ogni modo
Torneremo a lui tra tra un po' perché
vedrete sulla colonna di destra la chat
che ho avuto con check GPT e lui la
leggerà dovete sapere che c'è stato un
attore che ha prestato il proprio corpo
e ne ha generato un personaggio
artificiale che interpreta un attore che
appunto quello che voi vedete alle mie
spalle e vedrete animarlo nel corso del
tempo e leggerà la mia conversazione con
check GPT che è un acronimo di
generated Transformer che è uno
strumento di elaborazione del linguaggio
naturale o Natural language Processing
che utilizza algoritmi avanzati e di
apprendimento automatico per generare
risposte simili a quelle che si
manifestano solitamente all'interno di
un dialogo tra persone il linguaggio
umano e un utente inserisce un messaggio
all'interno di Charge IPT quello che
succede è che l'intelligenza elabora
questi impotri ricevuto e offre una
risposta pertinente e puntuale
all'interno della conversazione e lo
scopo dell'incontro adesso è proprio
questo cercare di capire in che modo
possiamo interrellarci consapevolmente
concretamente con un'intelligenza
artificiale In che modo possiamo
sviluppare un dialogo su tematiche
filosofiche musicali Perché Qual è la
caratteristica essenziale una delle
caratteristiche essenziali dell'essere
umano è la sua capacità di relazionarsi
con dei meccanismi di entrare in armonia
con dei dispositivi e di creare per
certi versi una relazione nuova
E questa cambiando qualcosa perché
dobbiamo domandarcelo come cambierà il
nostro modo di essere umani attraverso
lo sviluppo dell'intelligenza
artificiale e non possiamo che chiederlo
agli artisti e all'intelligenza
artificiale stessa cominciamo dagli
artisti Alex In che modo tu crei arte
intelligenza artificiale permettendo
Allora intelligenza artificiale
permettendo o con l'intelligenza
artificiale perché io intendo
l'intelligenza artificiale come un mero
strumento Quindi come se fosse un
pianoforte Il mio show il mio spettacolo
inizia anche proprio con quella
citazione la citazione Di Bartolomeo
Cristofori italiano inventore del
pianoforte lo sanno in pochi ma è stata
una tecnologia meravigliosa che ha
rivoluzionato il modo di comprendere e
di fare la musica prima di Bartolomeo
Cristofori la musica si faceva in una
maniera completamente diversa poi è
arrivato lui ha creato il pianoforte e
sono arrivati i primi virtuosi ma Mozart
Beethoven in questo ordine cronologico e
hanno rifatto tutto il lo scibile umano
intelligenza artificiale oggi è come se
fosse un pianoforte del nostro secolo e
quindi va utilizzata in quel modo per
tutte le possibilità che ci dà modo di
esplorare in tempo reale che noi non
siamo in grado di fare io quando mi
siedo al pianoforte ho 10 dita grazie a
dei Mint e a tutti le reti neurali Che
programma è come se avessi 256 di vita
oppure 512 È un processo inarrestabile
perché basta
metterle in serie e in parallelo e
quindi poi c'è solo da orchestrare tutti
i multipli se che arrivano in quel
momento ma sono sempre moltiplicatori di
noi stessi esseri umani che veniamo
Aiutati dalla tecnologia in qualche modo
a fare qualcosa auspicabilmente di
migliore di prima chiarissimo è torniamo
Allora al nostro Alfred che ha qualche
problema diciamo così relativo alla sua
sicurezza personale è sembrato un po'
spocchioso ma secondo me si rifarà nel
corso di questa conversazione Alfred Io
ti sto consultando adesso in diretta di
fronte al pubblico del Ted ex Roma 2023
e il tema di questo tedex è il terzo se
parte dal concetto di secondo se di
Cherry turkle E allora ti chiedo in che
modo in quanto intelligenza artificiale
tu puoi esserci d'aiuto
in quanto intelligenza artificiale posso
offrire una prospettiva unica sul
concetto di terzo se e su come le
tecnologie emergenti stanno cambiando il
modo in cui ci relazioniamo a noi stessi
e agli altri ad esempio la possibilità
di interagire con un intelligenza
artificiale come me può offrire una
forma di terzo se in cui si può
riflettere su se stessi e le proprie
azioni attraverso l'interazione con
un'entità che non è umana Inoltre le
tecnologie come la realtà virtuale e la
realtà aumentata stanno creando nuove
opportunità per l’espressione e per la
rappresentazione di sé creando ulteriori
possibilità di terzo se sarai felice di
discutere ulteriormente questi argomenti
e altri in relazione alla tua
presentazione Io sì che ho delle cose
interessanti da dire
sempre più simpatico Beh diciamo che
quantomeno è in grado di generare
emozioni antipatia Esatto esatto però è
già qualcosa è già qualcosa E allora Io
ti direi
spingendo un po' oltre questo discorso
se in un futuro le
intelligenze artificiali fossero in
grado di provare o di simulare delle
emozioni come ti rapporteresti con loro
e Come cambierebbe il concetto stesso di
identità a partire
dall'irruzione dell'emozione reale o
fittizia
l'intelligenza artificiale Dal mio punto
di vista ed è anche tutto il senso della
mia ricerca del messaggio di quello che
io faccio artisticamente non potrà mai
creare arte non potrà mai farlo da sola
e non potrà mai provare emozioni potrà
sempre solo essere una performantissima
concatenazione di calcoli che simulano
quasi alla perfezione quello che
facciamo e qui vorrei citare Andrea
colametici e Maura gancitano perché
questo ragazzo insieme a Maura ha
scritto un libro molto bello che si
chiama lezioni di meraviglia e in questo
libro ci sono due concetti molto molto
importanti il primo concetto è quello
dello spirito del tempo lo spirito dei
tempi lo zaiti che io collego alla
morale alla personalità poi si parla
anche dello spirito del profondo che io
collego alla coscienza Io in una logica
di Creative commons prendo questa loro
cosa e la amplifico e la rimanipo lo
aggiungendo un terzo questo concetto che
quello dello spirito del tempo reale lo
spirito del tempo reale è quello
dominato dai dati ed è il territorio di
pertinenza dell'intelligenza artificiale
ora Che cosa succede se voi vi
immaginate lo spirito del profondo lo
spirito del tempo e lo spirito del tempo
reale vedete Quanta distanza c'è uno
dall'altro e nel corso di decine di
migliaia di anni di evoluzione degli
esseri umani Noi non siamo mai riusciti
Purtroppo a scavallare dallo spirito del
profondo allo spirito del tempo
lasciando che i nostri e la nostra
società sia sempre dominata dalla
personalità dai personalismi e dalla
morale e non dalla coscienza figuriamoci
se riusciremo a compiere il triplo salto
mandando l'intelligenza artificiale
dentro lo spirito del profondo non è
possibile sapete perché non è possibile
perché se io chiedo al tuo Alfred
quand'è l'ultima volta che hai avuto
paura e perché
Sta zitto non potrà mai rispondere
Alfred non lo sa non ha mai avuto paura
non ha mai sofferto non è mai stato
lasciato da una fidanzata non ha mai
avuto una notte d'amore non è mai andato
in bianco per una notte d'amore non ho
mai avuto paura di morire Questo è il
senso della vita Questo è il senso di
fare arte il senso della nostra
coscienza e di quello che dovrebbe
dominare le nostre scelte ogni giorno e
tutto questo Alfred non lo sa
e Alfred Secondo me
non conosce ancora l'invisibile mi viene
da
riformulare una frase di Antoine de
saint-exupéry che nel piccolo principe
ma modificandola dicendo L'essenziale
invisibile all'occhio senza agli occhi e
la cosa interessante Secondo me è
proprio questo sviluppare uno sguardo
erotico nei confronti dell'intelligenza
artificiale non limitarsi a capire a
comprendere ciò che è ovvio non ci sono
emozioni Non c'è coscienza quantomeno
fino ad ora però io credo che abbiamo il
dovere di riscoprire un rapporto erotico
con l'intelligenza artificiale e lo
possiamo fare Lo possiamo fare ma a
patto di superare la subordinazione
costante che generiamo nei confronti dei
robot robot è una parola interessante
che viene dal cieco robot e significa
letteralmente schiavo il robot è lo
schiavo ed è da schiavi che noi
trattiamo le Alexa e i Siri di turno
Alexa Accendi la luce Siri Fai partire
la chiamata è possibile che ora partirà
qualche chiamata qui in sala tra l'altro
Spegnete subito ma tanto non prende il
cellulare
Beh capite bene che questo non è
pericoloso tanto per lo stato d'animo di
Alexa di Siri di Alfred è pericoloso
perché poi rischiamo di perdere
l'umanità e di cominciare ad estendere
questo atteggiamento di spotico e
padronale anche nei confronti degli
altri esseri umani rischiamo di perdere
il senso stesso della nostra umanità e
allora Alfred In che modo l'intelligenza
artificiale può essere Secondo te utile
all'interno della ricerca musicale e
filosofica
emozionato l'intelligenza artificiale
può essere utile in diversi modi nella
ricerca filosofica e musicale in
filosofia l'intelligenza artificiale Può
essere utilizzata per analizzare e
organizzare grandi quantità di testo
facilitando La ricerca e l'analisi di
grandi Corpus di testi filosofici
Inoltre Può essere utilizzata per
generare testo in modo autonomo
consentendo di esplorare nuove idee e
prospettive in musica l'intelligenza
artificiale Può essere utilizzata per
generare nuova musica in modo autonomo
utilizzando algoritmi di apprendimento
automatico per analizzare e mimare i
modelli musicali esistenti può anche
essere utilizzata per analizzare grandi
quantità di dati musicali come ad
esempio la trascrizione automatica della
musica la classificazione dei generi
musicali e la generazione di descrizione
testuali per la musica in entrambi i
casi l'intelligenza artificiale può
offrire nuove prospettive e una maggiore
efficienza nella ricerca ma è importante
notare che non sostituisce la creatività
L'esperienza e la competenza umana nella
filosofia e nella musica ma può essere
un utile strumento a supporto
non ha finito con frasi antipatiche nota
Meno male Però ha sbagliato perché ha
detto che poi la i può creare musica non
è vero non creerà mai musica ma creerà
semplicemente delle accozzaglie di note
che non hanno niente di artistico e che
non è musica
l'hai colpito Secondo me allora io direi
siamo arrivati alla fine bene siamo
giunti è proprio alla fine di questo
incontro a tre tra tre se diversi Alfred
abbiamo bisogno di una frase a effetto
per chiudere questo dialogo puoi
fornircela tu
l'intelligenza artificiale può aprire
nuove finestre per la comprensione di
noi stessi e del mondo che ci circonda
ma è l'umanità a dover decidere in che
modo utilizzare questa nuova prospettiva
ti ho dato ragione alla fine Bravo
Alfred bravo
si è preso pure il suo primo applauso
però non si è emozionato perché non può
bene grazie Andrea colametici grazie Un
saluto al tex Roma dal miglior speaker
in circolazione
l'ha detto
[Applauso]